Armed Forces former joint operational
Commander quite the title he's with us
now Ash Alexander Cooper good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning so we've heard that there
will be an evacuation of Brits the Brits
are coming as we were saying earlier it
says 48 72 hour ceasefire what happens
next
well it's clearly very welcome news for
those who've been waiting for some sort
of communication about what the plan
would be and obviously their families
who are worried and waiting for news as
well for for what might be happening
it's a really complex time and very very
unstable so even though we have very
welcome news also that there's a
ceasefire potentially for up to 72 hours
you know the history of the last 10 days
shows that that there's no guarantee
that the fighting won't continue so it
remains very unpredictable but it's good
news to hear that the British have have
now moved more sort of actively and then
evacuation appears to be starting
um so we'll have to wait and see how
that plays out how do we do it what
happens well the trouble is this this
country is so large that there are no
really good options I mean there's talk
of Port Sudan being potentially used
with Naval vessels to extract people
from the sea but that's still 525 miles
away from Khartoum so that's a pretty
you know difficult Journey for anybody
who's trying to make it that far
um air clearly is the fastest way out
but the capacity on helicopters or
airplanes is is more limited so you know
land would be the the way to get the
most people out most quickly if this
window is really small but clearly
that's quite dangerous if you get caught
up in checkpoints or or the the message
hasn't filtered down to the most Junior
commanders that there is a ceasefire
because that is always the risk in these
kind of I was going to say how do you
trust the system well this is exactly it
you know the highest level if the
commanders have agreed one thing that's
great but if as we understand
communication is pretty difficult in
country right now there's no guarantee
that the junior commanders will have
heard that or they're trying to make a
name for themselves so the risk to life
is still very high and therefore it's a
risk calculus not just for those on the
ground but for the British government
and the prime minister to determine
which option is the best one to achieve
the outcome that they seek it's only a
72-hour window at most though so I'm
guessing a lot of preparation has
already been done yeah the military team
at permanent joint headquarters here in
London this is really why they exist to
manage operations overseas they will
have been conducting contingency
planning for weeks if not months to work
up every available and potential option
that might work so it's really going to
be them presenting this to to the
government to determine what is within
the risk appetite of the government and
which is most likely to achieve the aim
but it's a really small window if even
if it does hold for 72 hours there's
still 4 000 people that need to be he
got out that's going to take time and
there's still a risk if we've learned
one thing from Afghanistan and that
withdrawal although the situations are
are different is that every minute and
every hour counts we can't be complacent
and hope that the ceasefire lasts longer
than 72 hours we must plan that every
hour is our last and do everything we
can the reason I ask you sir is because
of course you were a Britain's permanent
joint you worked in Britain's permanent
joint headquarters um The Hub of the UK
planning for overseas military
operations so you know exactly what
needs to be done to get as many people
out as possible can we get 4 000 people
out that are spread across this country
in 72 hours
well that is that is the challenge
that's another the issue but this is not
a a solely a British effort you know we
work very closely in partnership with
our allies the US and others who have a
bigger presence in the region so I would
imagine that there's a lot of
coordination going on between the Brits
and all those other countries in the EU
the US and elsewhere to ensure that if
there's capacity or options to help get
people out if there's space then we'll
be working very much hand in glove with
them is it doable
I believe it is doable
um but it's going to take a lot of Will
from the government to actually you know
coordinate itself and communicate
clearly I think the biggest risk apart
from the distance and the other things
we've already talked about is
communication you know if if people
don't get the message and that certainly
happened in Afghanistan people didn't
receive the email or the text message in
time to get to the evacuation point and
then there is a risk clearly that people
might be left behind and then if the
situation deteriorated further then I
don't know what they would do but how do
you how do you get the message to people
on the ground who potentially don't have
any electricity I don't have any other
form of communication with the outside
world yeah that that is the problem I
mean I believe there is still text
messaging but it's the communication as
I read somewhere today that it's down to
two percent of what would be normal uh
Ways and Means to communicate so that is
going to be very very hard which is why
the government must be extremely
explicit and clear with simple
instructions for those who are who have
been to this point been told to shelter
in place and not go outside
um they will need to know very clearly
what to do because they'll be panicked
scared and there's still you know a huge
risk of once they've left their
apartment that they'll bump into
roadblocks or young Fighters that
haven't got the message that fighting is
is over for now yeah I mean people
hiding under the bed yeah and they need
to know that they need to leave
everything now and go to either the port
or the airport and and that's the only
way to get out of the country we have
viewers who are watching us who have
people still in Sudan family and friends
if they do manage to communicate with
them what should they be saying
well I mean one would hope that the
government's plan will let them know
depending on where they are but if not
um it's a difficult one because you know
the moment you leave your building or
your house there is a huge increase to
risk to life but if you stay and
fighting does resume or you know it's
fighting the fighting continues around
your house and that's also equally a
risk particularly if you're running out
of water food or medicine if people need
medicine so there are no good options
here really but it's encouraging as I
said at the start that an evacuation
appears to be underway and the
government has moved faster than perhaps
some were expecting
um albeit you know reports that they are
slightly behind some of their European
Partners but communication will be key
and speed is of the essence now let me
just finish that point then I'll come on
to what you would just saying what would
you say to your loved ones if they were
trapped in Sudan at the moment if I had
if I had family there if I was there
myself
um if I had a window of opportunity that
I thought was safe enough based on my
risk calculus then I would try and get
to somewhere where I believe that I'd be
safer and further away from the fighting
and then work out how to get to the port
or an airport from there
um but how would you assess your risk
well I've had military training and I've
been in these hostile environments for
many years in my life so I you know I
maybe my risk appetite is is higher
um but it's just absorbing anything you
can in terms of news and updates and and
trying to work out with local Partners
as well I mean all these people who are
living in Sudan or have been posted to
work there will likely have local
networks and and that kind of
information could be absolutely valuable
for them in terms of understanding what
might be safe enough to be able to get
to a place that would allow them to be
extracted
saying you know how absolutely
fascinating it is and and of course you
know the challenges because you've been
in that position but what about people
who who don't know the risks
yeah I mean it's it's terrifying you
know if you are in your apartment hiding
under your bed as you said and you're
running out of water and you're running
out of food and it you can hear gunfire
outside your house it is traumatizing
and I think that's another thing that
the government must start already to be
thinking about is that even when we do
extract these people safely that what
services are we going to be able to
provide them for the children who may be
traumatized having seen fighting or been
wrapped up in it themselves they may
have been wounded or had family members
hurt or seen other their friends um kill
the wounded so that is another issue
that needs to be thought about now and
not wait and I wondered if I might just
be able to pick up on the point that
you're making about the fact that other
countries have brought out Nationals
before we have and in fact the French I
think have brought out British Nationals
dual Nationals
um
did we act quickly enough
it would appear that we acted
fast faster than certainly I was
expecting us to to act but all these
things these things are never simple or
tidy they're always complex and
unpredictable and messy that's just the
reality on the ground but I can safely
say hand on heart that all of those
military folks who are involved in the
planning and the execution of these
extractions will have been doing the
planning from for many weeks if not
months and they will be doing everything
they can on the ground and accept that
the risk to life is is very real and
they'll do anything they can to protect
that life and get people out
okay it's good to see you thanks for
taking the time much appreciate it thank
you